♫ Me and Gary Vee up in the office
♫ Do rag flapping,
walking through corporate
♫ Talks about all this shit then leverage
♫ 1,800 cheques to share out of average
("What Dreams Are Made
Of" by Iiinfinite.Music)
♫ Infinite
- What up, what up, what up?
Good morning.
I'm lagging on a lives,
so trying to,
trying to up my game a
little bit on the lives.
Oh, and this gets saved
now, and goes to stories,
so big shout out everybody if
you're watching my stories.
D-Rock's three year
anniversary at Vayner Media.
Happy birthday, D-Rock.
- [D-Rock] Thank you.
- Three.
How's yesterday's DailyVee?
Mainly about the USC football?
- [D-Rock] Yep.
- Dang right.
Straight up, for 90% of you,
this is the greatest year
of your life, right now.
Little bit of the call with Colin.
- [D-Rock] Yep.
- It's how you make it.
- [D-Rock] Are we in a rant?
- Are we in a rant?
Are you?
Fabricate it.
(muffled speaking)
If your shit's good right
now, quadruple down.
To me, I don't even think
about it as cold calling
I think of it as more of like
business development, right?
You know, it's like you're
introducing yourself.
And so, the word cold calling
speaks to just high volume
don't give a fuck.
To me it's strategic introduction.
Cold calling, strategic introductions.
Si.
I can brand this whole thing like si.
Like yes.
2017 flip challenge.
There's all money just
sitting in people's how,
people want money.
People are spending their lives
trying to figure out how to
raise $25,000 for a startup,
and they're sitting with $25,000
in fucking clothes, garbage.
Or, in hustle.
Like just driving around and midnight
and picking up people's free shit
that they put out on the curb.
I know it sounds dirty,
but I like dirty.
I'm into dirty.
Dirty's how you win.
Dirty's all you've got
when you got nothing.
Look, if you don't want dirty,
be lucky and be born into a trust fund.
You know?
Win the lotto.
But,
when you're fucking dirty,
when you're coming from zero,
you gotta scrap.
Because complaining on your
social media or at the bar
ain't gonna get you shit.
Nothing.
Gusac.
Fucking zero.
(clicking)
Cool, what else could I do
here before I've got this call
in five minutes?
Dunc, the most boring DailyVee
ever because it's true.
(laughs) What?
I don't know which one that was.
You know what's crazy?
If I made $70,000 a year I'd be set.
I'd be real happy.
I don't need anything.
- [D-Rock] Yep.
- When you don't need anything,
when you don't expect
anything from others,
when you don't need anything,
when you love losing,
when you don't give a fuck
about what other people think,
you become fundamentally unbeatable.
And that's what I am.
I'm un-fucking-beatable
because
of humility,
empathy,
that's it man.
Fucking, it's cool.
Like, it's starting to be interesting
how I'm like starting to figure it out.
I'm like, oh, okay.
You can't beat me, what are you gonna do?
What are you gonna do?
What are you gonna say?
I like it.
I want more chips on my shoulder.
I like, why do you think
I love the Jets so much?
Like, it's true though.
- [D-Rock] Oh yeah?
- Two videos put out by (beep).
One shows the brand in
the first three seconds,
the other one is just much better
and people give a fuck.
That one will sell more (beep).
That's real life.
I understand.
That's fine.
And what we're pointing to is
common sense and real life,
and a world that trades on things
that aren't the metrics
that guide the spend.
And I'm not naive to think
that that's not a vulnerability
but we have to have a
point of view on this
that is gonna make us in
a 30 years macro correct.
Again, I think you guys
have heard this from me,
we will put the brand in
the first three seconds
in every video as long as (beep)
and (beep) know that we
think they're shitfaces
for making us do it.
The end.
Hi.
♫ Ooh
- Heya.
- [Gary] Hello.
- How are you?
- Welcome, good to see you.
- Good to see you.
Morning guys.
- Hey, how are you doing?
- Morning, how are you?
♫ Ooh
Good, how are you?
- Yeah, good.
- Good.
Good morning.
("Promise Land" by James Gardin)
- [Woman] Good morning.
♫ Yo, sweet Jesus
♫ Hop on the track like what up dope
♫ I know who I am, but they
thinking they're to sharp
♫ Running a scam like cuckold
♫ But I have a plan, I hope
you plan to keep up though
♫ I don't think you understand
♫ That you're greater than
that life they try to sell you
♫ So hold up there's
something I need to tell you
♫ And I think that this
thing could really help you
♫ These suckers try to tell
us that we can't shake it
♫ But my God, I know where we can take it
♫ And I know everyday
you facin' your giants
♫ But my God, I believe
we dance in the triumph
♫ Now let me it take
you to the promised land
♫ Let's go, let's go, let's go
♫ Let me take you to the promised land
- Awesome.
- Good.
- Oh, right, let me see, let
me say goodbye to Instagram.
♫ Promised land
- And thank you guys.
Yo, yo, yo, email this
address and say biz-def
if you are a sneaker shop owner,
an owner of Instagram accounts,
or profiles that play in that arena.
Super grateful, driven by gratitude.
Actually, I need a driven
by gratitude t-shirt.
Right?
Tyler, can you fucking design that shit?
In the next hour?
Driven by fucking gratitude.
See ya.
Eddie, were you reading,
or were you watching?
- [Eddie] I was (drowned out
by talking over each other)
a little bit.
- [Gary] What was the vibes?
- Lot of shoes sizes cash in.
- [Gary] Yep.
- Lot of people pumped.
I mean,
- [Gary] Good vibes.
- A lot of people just
wanted to get on the phone.
(laughing)
Complaining about what's being
talked about on the phone.
- I think the best thing
that's happened to me
in running Vayner was
me coming to the company
and saying project
management should be out,
and then bringing it back.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I think my genius is me accepting
that I'm a super naked emperor.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
I think that's good.
- That's how you win.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I don't think I'm a genius,
I think I just am always evolving.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- And I'm never bought into my own shit.
The signature creative
will be long form video
for the mobile device
on probably Facebook.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- That's the proper statement.
- Like in 48 months,
if it's Snapchat, if it's
Red Shoe, if it's MySpace
has come back, I don't know.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I don't really care.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- It's the internet.
- [Interviewer] But it's
not gonna be a 30 second--
- But it's not gonna be a 30 second spot.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Gary] It's impossible.
- [Gary] And that's a big sea change.
- Yeah, sure.
- [Gary] That's a trillion
dollar sea change.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- Because when you compound
all the digital marketing
that ladders up to the 30 second spot,
it's not a,
it's not just the money
poured into a commercial.
- [Interviewer] Sure.
- It's the impact on everything.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- It's the glue that holds down
every brand's communication.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- It is the piece.
When that breaks, all hell breaks loose.
♫ Let me take you to the promised land
♫ Let's go, let's go, let's go
♫ Let me take you the promised land
- Okay, sure.
- Yep.
♫ There will always be more
doubters than supporters
(muffled speaking)
- Alright.
(laughing)
Wow.
Alright, let me go.
- [Gary] Can you grab a chair for me?
Thanks.
(muffled speaking)
(laughing)
- It's there even more
than I thought.
- Hello.
- [Group] Hi.
- How are you?
You might've even saw
it before you even came.
I believe in it the most.
There's nothing you're gonna learn here
that trumps becoming
friends with Madelana,
or Matt Sitimer, it's just inconceivable.
The end.
You should really,
(laughing)
literally, fundamentally you should.
You may introverted, or quiet,
like I don't know you, right?
But whatever you can do.
And I think the right thing to do
is try to bring value too.
Like, hey, I know I'm on
the inside strategy team,
but hey creative, you know, Sally,
like is there anything I can do for you?
And it's more not like you
should be working 28 hours,
it's like, if you're gonna,
like, here's the thing.
If you're gonna stay to
show that you're a hustler,
think you wanna work here.
After this.
And you're like, okay, good way to do it,
I know Gary's spiel, and like
I'm gonna stay here 'til nine.
That's gonna be like, they're gonna see.
Which would be a strategy.
It'd be really smart if you
did something of meaning
towards a relationship in that four hours.
Work for the sake of work,
you know what I mean?
It does speak to hard work and effortless,
and I think a lot of the
things I've done in my career
were not smart, but I just willed 'em
through sheer volume and effort.
But, what is so much
cooler is breaking shit
through relationships.
Like if you work on your
required account thing
from nine to six, it would
probably less scrutinized
if you were helping somebody in production
from eight to 10.
It may be scrutinized.
I mean, most of the
company still falls, like,
when you're an employee of
a company you're like, well,
this is our rule, like I would get that.
But it's that's interesting.
Or just like, hanging out with each other.
The relationships are,
they only are a why.
It just they are.
The skillsets are gonna change too much.
Right?
The skillsets are gonna change.
The principles are tried and true.
Your talent is your talent.
Your work ethic is your work ethic.
But it's the relationships, right?
♫ There will always be more
doubters than supporters
♫ When the vigil seems too big
♫ They either gonna hate or ignore ya
♫ I guess it is what it is
♫ But you just gotta stay focused
- Thanks for joining us this summer.
♫ Don't put your hope in the hopeless.
- [Interns] Thank you.
- Yeah, this was fun.
♫ Remember that you are our Joseph.
- Cool.
(muffled chattering)
Okay guys.
Talk to you guys soon.
Tula, did you take my bag?
(muffled speaking)
♫ God I know where we can take this
- Well listen, this is why I
keep trying to tell you guys.
(muffled speaking)
Hey guys, I just made a
D-Rock idea way better.
We're putting out a lot more
content on article form.
Yes, that's Ted DiBiase,
the million dollar man.
We're gonna have a fan
each week read the article
from my podcast, details to come.
Who likes to read?
Hey guys, first of all
thank you so, so much
for being part of Gary Vee 365.
As you guys know, I'm obsessed with voice.
Good morning, good
afternoon, happy midday.
I'm obsessed with voice.
And I'm just humbled that
you're part of these early days,
reminds me of my first
5,000 followers on Twitter.
So thank you, thank you, thank you, and.
♫ Remember just refocus on the goal
♫ Ooh
♫ And stop moving slow
♫ Take these boxing gloves
♫ No one rock the boat
- See you in a little bit.
♫ Just refocus on the goal
♫ Now let me take you to the promised land
♫ Let's go, let's go, let's go
♫ Let me take you the promised land
♫ Let me take you to the promised land
♫ Let's go, let's go, let's go
♫ Ooh